you aren't supposed to be this far from
the palace Ariel let's go back oh god
what the sorry that was that is
terrifying
hello my fish name is
but you can call me Ron and as you can
see I am a real non-cgi fish so I'm
going to be watching this new Little
Mermaid movie and telling you what they
got right and what they got wrong about
life uh under the sea
are mermaids real yes but they don't
look how you think you ever stay in the
bath too long and your hands get all
pruney just imagine that but like all
over they definitely don't have any of
that what do you call it um hair I don't
know if you've noticed no one has hair
underwater
[Music]
okay so we haven't had a king of the sea
since like Poseidon all right fish
abolished the monarchy a while ago
because it was pretty nasty anyway we're
a constitutional republic now learn
about other countries flounder stopping
such a guppy wow okay uh she can't use
that word that's our word
oh
you know people think sharks are these
amazing Hunters but they can't even swim
backwards all you got to do is get
behind them super easy to with why
do they even call him a flounder anyway
he's not a flounder they'd be like
calling a British guy Frenchie doesn't
make any sense
eels actually not so bad in my
experience they can be pretty
electrifying in the seabed if you know
what I mean Slither up all kinds of
oh sorry this is a kids movie uh I'll
stop walking around on those what do you
call them oh
feet wait she doesn't know the word for
feet Scuttle has feet we're fish not
idiots
come back flounder it's just Scuttle hey
uh that bird just ate another fish right
in front of you why are you hanging out
with her like she's your friend she just
ate your cousin
all the feasts we had when I lived in
the palace
we do all eat shrimp though while we
devote in full time to floating Under
the Sea full-time floating yeah I've got
a job it's called trying not to die I'm
your auntie Ursula
with the sea witch yes we have sea
witches just like you have land witches
we even had sea witch trials but of
course we couldn't burn them at the
stake or drown them in a lake because
you know so we had to get creative you
have recalamari those are the squids who
didn't accept Jesus
oh well carcass Town hey they must have
shot this a few years ago because it's
been totally gentrified now see that rib
that's a sweet green
[Music]
but true still above praise where praise
is due Sebastian told
I didn't
flounder buddy it can wait you're dying
ah there we go up here
is key to the coast no no that's
fishburg those Waters rule Uncharted
that's West fishburg that place sucks
you know how hard it is to find one fish
in the entire ocean pretty hard we don't
have smartphones well that worked pretty
good didn't it but nothing's happened
wow did flounder swim all the way from
saltwater into fresh water you know how
much that friggin Burns
hey come on we are not all
bioluminescent okay this isn't Pandora
I'll see him reggae like a woman
guys we don't have smoke underwater I I
honestly can't believe I have to point
this out remember that's why
[Applause]
I'm good music no okay but but the guy
who wrote it is one of your most
acclaimed musicians yes yes uh make it
make sense
hey you guys ever see Luca that one was
good not enough people saw Luca we made
a deal
in blood it's unbreakable yeah she's not
wrong I tried to get out of a Blood Oath
once they just kept transferring me to
different customer service raise until I
changed sex at a pure boredom
actually this bit about whirlpools all
being caused by giant Melissa McCarthy's
is actually accurate not many people
realize that
oh that's nice that they ended up
together now she can release her
thousands of eggs under the floor of the
boat and he can fertilize them on top
from a distance that's how it works with
you guys too right
well I hope this has been enlightening I
gotta get back in the water before I dry
out but remember don't dump in the ocean
and let James Cameron know he's welcome
anytime we love that guy stay dry losers
foreign
[Music]